we're gonna do if maybe a few episodes
not sure exactly how will come out as
but on the design of social software or
collaborative software we're going to
kind of do a bit of a mix so there we go
with a less spinny chair and see if I
stay still so we're going to start with
the kind of 20 plus years of research
that have underwritten the design of
that type of system and then connect
that to things that we see a lot more of
now which is communication social
platforms like theirs or snapchat things
of that so one of the theories we talked
about in the filter bubbles video that
was if a while ago is common ground and
that's the idea that you know what other
people know about you and what you both
know fact there's a good definition
that's a common ground refers to the
knowledge that people share and they
know the other shares that's important
bits oh no well I know that you know
that we both know is a kind of
complicated but important aspect of how
we collaborate and that helps us to
determine a bit like who our friends are
social networks but it equally makes
collaboration easier if we're going to
use software the other aspects of why we
collaborate is people's readiness to do
it or willingness to do it if you're
being forced to do it that's not really
a great way but if you are being forced
then you need other things to be easier
to make it worth it and then the other
aspect is technology technology
readiness and that's where we've made a
lot of progress in this 20 plus years
when we're looking at software for
collaboration is making it better and
easier for people to collaborate the
most important thing you need we're
going to start referring to some paper
now is to think about who is using it
when and why so if we have a nice
initial grid when we have time over here
and place here and then if this is the
same and this is different and then this
is the same and this is different we
have then for possible quadrants of how
people are collaborating so if they're
in the same time in the same place like
in a meeting room or two people are in
the same room in coding this would be
the same time same place it might be
that you're in the same time but
different places and so this is when
people are working together at the same
time but from two different parts of the
country or two different countries but
you know not physically together that
might be a Skype call or something like
yeah yeah that's a good example
and then you've got same place for
different
and this is people maybe working shifts
or maybe you've been working on a
project and then someone else taking
over next week while you're away so
that's the same place technology that's
there but working at different times and
then you've got a different time
different place which is working in
different time zones on the same system
so you're not working together that
makes sense but you are trying to
collaborate you could also have a
dimension in there which is the number
of people who are collaborating but
that's gonna start getting messy and
we'll start doing that later but this is
a nice initial framing I think and it's
one that comes up a lot in research and
just in the design of software so the
real question there is what do you lose
when you're moving away from the same
time same place so if you and I are in
the same time same place working
together I could see that you're nodding
because you I've not said something
stupid you're approving of what I'm
saying and that's a little subtle
communication nonverbal body language
that you're saying to me and you don't
see that if you're in different places
or different times and there's lots of
aspects like this which are important
for people working together that you
just miss out on so there's body
language there's nonverbal communication
so kind of grunting to say that you
approve yeah hmm this type of thing is
also missed out unless you've got a live
audio stream and then if you do have a
live audio stream then maybe you don't
know who when because there might be
four or five people and you just miss
the connection between I guess the only
thing you have is exactly what people
type in or exactly what people say and
so you need to build that into your
software somehow this is our key
challenge and to do that we're going to
talk about something different and now
we're gonna get Lego involved and more
importantly it's quite popular I got the
strawberry laces this is going to help
us to cuz strawberry laces are both
useful and delicious so let's get aboard
we need board and then we also need some
people to help us so I'm gonna have Yoda
you're just gonna help us help you he
will yeah he's gonna sit right there
hopefully and stay there and then
there's something that Yoda wants to
work on so this is his document in the
middle or it could be some code some
collaborative work some coders are
working on and then in between that and
this is an important separation is we
have a user interface and this is
something
and mister when people think about it
they just presume as a person in the
computer but actually there's a person
the user interface and then the artifact
that they're working on and so I'm
actually going to take the top of the
user interface off just for ease and
stick that back on do you do there we go
so when we're working on a software one
of the key design principles for user
interfaces that you get good feedback on
what's happening and this might be that
if you're working on a Word document
when you press save it then says it was
saved if it doesn't say it was saved you
think did it save and you're worried
about how's it safe so you don't if you
don't have the feedback then use it and
so what's what is this this is someone
interacting with the documents pressing
save and then what they want is to get
the feedback to know that it's happened
I'm going to pull that off there because
that's tasty and I can eat that later so
this bit of strawberry lace there is
recognizing that the person interacts
with the artifact through the user
interface it's gone through the whole
there if we can see hopefully and then
he's got some feedback back to him to
say that whatever he did happened it
could also be like if you press bold on
some text you can actually go bold not
just trust that someone else would one
day see it go bold and this idea of
feedback is a key principle for user
interface design which is fine but now
we are going to talk about collaborative
software so it's not just Yoda
interacting with that document or a user
interface there's multiple people trying
to it so if we can imagine that Anakin
also wants to get involved
these pieces were chosen by my son by
the way to help this communication we're
also gonna bring in evil a jar gives us
if Lord in this one
and for the fun of it we're going to
have what does he stick down maybe we'll
see
bathtime Batman he might help to you now
they all want to work on this document
together yeah and they all want feedback
fair enough
they've all got a user interface to work
through this is where I break everything
so there we go we have four people four
user interfaces one document they're all
trying to work on and I think maybe we
should get rid of path time Batman he's
just gonna fall over
sorry bath time Batman we had to go so
let's just work it with three people
Yoda
Anakin and evil Jar Jar I'm trying to
work through there user interfaces with
the artifacts they all want some
feedback but to save time I'm not gonna
put multiple laces in for them but the
thing we need to know as well as
feedback on our action
is to know what other people are doing
and we call this feed through instead of
feedback so the artifacts going to feed
through what the other people are doing
to say Anakin is making a change on the
system well let's add his own feedback
why not he's got some feedback to say
he's made some changes on the system
that's fine he knows what he's doing so
how does Yoda know what he's doing
we also need a connection which is
Anakin interacting with it and then
telling Yoda what happened so now Yoda
knows that Anakin may be edited a
paragraph or is editing a paragraph at
the moment and samey jaja jaja wants to
add in a picture to this documents and
Yodo wants to know that it happened so
now you can see that
Yodas got quite a few bits of
information that's coming through he's
got his own feedback and he's got
information fed through about what other
people are doing and this is a the key
issue that we're asking ourselves for
collaborative software is what
information do we need to feed through
that is replacing our knowledge what
people are doing because they're not in
the same room as us or not working at
the same time as us but presumably each
of those guys would also have that same
amount
yeah yeah so Jar Jar it's not just Yoda
that wants to know what charter did
Anakin wants to know what Jar Jar did
actually Anakin jaja wants to know what
he did himself so he's got to have his
own back and also George I wants to know
what Anakin did so now they all have
feedback on what they're doing
themselves and and as many bits of feed
through from what other people are doing
yeah and so if you've got like 12 people
collaborating which I'm not that many
LEGO pieces with me today we then have
quite a lot of feed through coming
through and feedback you're gonna get to
a point where you reach a limit in terms
of what your user interface can tell you
because if your interface has got to
show you the document you're working on
give you feedback on what you're doing
and reserve space for what other people
are doing and data about that then
you've suddenly got a lot of design
that's being focused on what other
people are doing alongside what you're
doing and alongside the doctor when
you're working on so say then you if you
want to we could let's say maybe you
want to have some direct video chat on
there as well then you've got another
bit of string not going by artifact just
directly connecting all of them which
are that's going to start getting really
but your user interface has got to
handle a lot so you've gone from kind of
standard user interface concerns of
usability or feedback to kind of
conveying what everybody's doing from
different times and different places so
if it's a different place it might just
be live action of what they're doing and
if it's a different time we might be
somehow a historical record of what they
did or maybe kind of a replay of what
they did let's talk about Google Docs as
an example so one feature you see in
Google Docs is a kind of colored icon
moving around where their cursor is on
the document and if it's near yours and
if they select a whole paragraph you
then see that whole paragraph come up in
their color so this is an example of
feeds were coming through the artifact
document being highlighted by the user
interface to show you what they were
doing and what they were highlighting
well what does that not tell you that
doesn't tell you where their current
screen is tells you where the current
cursor is or what texts are currently
highlighted you could imagine Google
Docs could also highlight for you like a
rectangle on the document showing you
where their viewport is currently on the
system and that presumes their viewport
as active so you could also have it kind
of they've got a window in the
background and that shows you that that
person is not interacting with you so
they're off playing solitaire or yeah
sometimes you think well they're
thinking really hard about that
paragraph for a long time and you
realize they're not they're just at
luncheon so in this third dimension
we're talking about is being termed
telepresence and that's because it's
been related to lots of things like
virtual reality as well but it's the
extent to which your physical presence
has been recreated somewhere else so if
we had say was to take Skype you talk
about Skype really that's giving you
kind of full picture maybe high
definition of someone we can see kind of
maybe their kind of portrait photo type
shape so you've got a head and shoulders
that tells you maybe some of the facial
language but maybe not entire body
language so it's been quite well
represented to someone else Google Docs
takes a kind of low at low rate level
and it just sort of has metadata in
their service you've got some signs of
their actions represented by where their
cursor is but not kind of full view of
them so they has a low a low
telepresence of that person
and so you're asking yourself with that
theory
how much telepresence or how much
recreation of the person do we need is
it going to be important to know that
someone's thinking in Google Docs versus
are there working oh yeah so is it gonna
be worth putting in a whole video
section to use a whole portion of the
screen to say that you want full res
bids video we see that a lot in our
films the s being self-made up in 3d
graphics and actually in Star Wars you
see them having these kind of hologram
conversations with people as if they're
in the room there's obviously a
potential bandwidth issue here I mean
you can only fit so much to release
through those bits of like oh sure yeah
so actually one thing I mentioned
earlier was number of people involved in
it and so if you're imagining working on
a document with a set number of people
it's fine to try and convey what each
person is doing but when you're talking
about a crowd which is what we're tend
to be talking with Facebook or Twitter
or snapchat or anything like that we
tend to be getting kind of summative
different time different place numbers
about what we've got so number of
retweets which could have been any time
when you log back in xtr i've had an
extra 50 retweets or something on that
and this is giving us a kind of a more
scalable different time different place
feed through of what people been doing
so we've talked about some theories now
which we're going to refer back to in
the next couple of videos and what we're
going to do over the next couple of
videos is look at the specific example
of how a feature of Twitter has been
designed and how people use it and
difference between what it's designed
for and how it's used and then we're
going to come back at the end and talk
about a range of other software and some
social phenomenon that exists because of
how the software is designed and how you
can change the software to maybe
influence how that for social phenomenon
happens
so sometimes he floppies wood dies he
often would make backup copies let's try
this one sounds more hopeful
taking a break
[Music]